[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bring me Inspector Gadget okay that is
the Thursday show I've always wanted to
do that we have been Shapiro today Alex
Epstein Thursday live on the youtubes
glad to see you today presuming me in
video studio as always is Jared who is
not K follow him on Twitter at not gay
Jared me at s credit with your comments
thoughts photoshop's left the family
elongation show your own conclusions are
we good we're good at G Morgan Jr yeah
how are you sir I'm doing great good
Inspector Gadget Spector gadget horrible
motion pictures it was the kind of
motion picture that was so bad and
ruined the cartoon it made you go back
and look at the cards sisters I can't I
can't enjoy it right now you ruined it
so we have maybe oka nothing mask you
brought a new color you call that a film
we have and the sequel was French
Stewart it doesn't get any worse Alex
Epstein author of the moral case for
fossil fuels and of course ben shapiro
will be talking about Comey
will be till i have a macro issue i want
to get into today because i received an
email from quite a few students saying
you know and I feel as though something
comes up all the time in college can you
help me out with that so we'll talk
about that with a lot of news to get to
videos a lot of news a lot of news a lot
of guests but let's hit some news off
the top texas bill now there's a bill in
texas that just passed that could
potentially keep transgenders out of
high school sports that doors it has the
left outraged because if this happens
what kind of society would we be
goodnight boys setting girls track meet
records or winning wrestling meets or
this
[Music]
it could be a chemical bomb in heaven to
dress it funny fast Fallon Fox a nailed
a female transgender who beats the hell
out of women in the cage for a living
and this goes back to I mean it's one of
those things where again because we read
leftist websites all the time yeah I sit
there and I just read the outrage and I
first read their outrage until I see
what the bill is about and it's more so
targeting steroids but because of
hormone replacement therapy which is
really bad for people it also would
include that okay it's a chemical
advantage and it's only happening in
Texas and in California they think we're
the crazy ones they always say it's
completely invalid it's just logically
lazy to use the slippery slope argument
yeah look behind you
there's the slippery slope now do me a
favor look in front of you that's a
200-foot drop covered in KY I would not
slide down that slide no no I know it's
waiting for you the bottom like I guess
AIDS you're right hit-and-run this
happened again another news story you
don't read about this in the leftist
websites but a hit and run DUI injured
his six-year-old so here's the kicker
the guy who committed the hit-and-run
he's already been deported
fifteen times as an illegal immigrant on
this is this is not a joke which is not
it's not a surprise to any of us who've
known about these problems with repeat
offenders at the border and as a matter
of fact here's right now for those who
don't believe it's live footage of the
American Mexican border
[Music]
we need to build that wall and not put a
door like no no it almost seems as
though it would cost more budget to put
that door the door out of the place
superfluous masseuse Tori's right off
the top right away it's the victim
culture creating actual victims girls in
high school
get in the crap beaten out of them not
being able to compete in sports and
right here we want to be we want to be
kind to illegal immigrants so what
happens DUI these people come over and
they commit crimes in record numbers and
so you see real victims but it's not as
politically expedient for the left today
tend to care about the six-year-old what
the hit-and-run yeah boat so speaking of
the left BuzzFeed yellow changed their
branding I guess I don't know how long
ago this happened pretty recent BuzzFeed
yellow to boldly boldly they say it's
the same content you know and love just
bolder and that's their content if you
haven't been following BuzzFeed yellow
they have 7 million subscribers on
YouTube it's namely social justice women
just trying out things that they've
never done before like a Kardashian diet
shoes this one the women of BuzzFeed
wearing heels for the first time a good
luck next up on suggestions of lists for
bold E's chicks to try not being a fat
lesbian it's gonna be that one be in the
dock yeah gonna be tough
the production value that needs yeah a
lot of new hires
it's like putting Clint Howard in
prosthetics someone who really knows
what they're doing why are you joking
about me like that Betsy DeVos this has
been going on all week so we'll talk
about call me with Ben Shapiro because
we talked about it yesterday for those
who missed it weren't mug Club members
go watch it I'd I'd rather hear what
been asked to say I'm exhausted but
Betsy DeVos this this did you read about
this earlier in the Inc there was
outrage over her giving a commencement
speech she was scheduled to so students
were protesting I was graduating senior
said I don't know how we presume Cookman
University in Florida something like
that anyways the speech happened anyway
with Betsy DeVos and this is how these
members of higher learning reacted let's
let's roll this clear
so as you can see they want to make
their voices heard and turning their
back because that's how adults react
[Applause]
University class of 2017
but it never be said that they were
disrespectful graduation they ruin their
own graduation and how many times do you
I don't know if these people weren't
officially black lives matter I don't
think so I don't want to misrepresent
them but obviously of that ilk how many
times that we heard black lives matter
talk about wanting to start a
conversation yeah yeah or a dialogue
right that's the end of the conversation
right there
there is no it's stopping a conversation
yes by the way these kids are so
ignorant they have no what does I Betsy
DeVos is not qualified for the job she's
not the most qualified person for the
job sure okay but let's get into where
ideas her ideas I don't know these kids
have no clue she advocates for school
choice that's her biggest sin here and
do you realize that these kids from from
from from urban areas from more poor
areas the United States they stand to
benefit the most from school choice from
attaching the voucher directly to the
student by the way I'm still waiting
we've had an open call out anyone who
wants to come on this show and make a
compelling case against school choice
I'm all ears anyone at any point I've
never heard it any of you no no can
anybody play devil's advocate I wouldn't
know where does not me for teachers
unions because they care about the kids
that's not speaking of college along
with college and other racist hopes at
another college this was a racist letter
that was written about it was in the
news allegedly including the n-word that
was posted but just like mattress girl
and pasta cos in the Duke Lacrosse case
it turned out to be false this one was
at Saint Olaf in Minnesota now the
president of the school confirmed that
the note was not a legitimate threat
that's what he said and then when
pressed on what what do you mean by it
was not a legitimate threat the
president said the reason I said in my
earlier note that this was not a genuine
threat it's that we learned from the
author's confession that the note was
fabricated so in other words the reason
is it wasn't because it's not a real
thing it never it's not a real thing
it's a fake it's a lie and he says
apparently it was a strategy to draw
attention to concerns about the campus
climate again the ends justify the means
here because apparently the concern was
to draw attention to fake incidents of
racism on college check
I don't exactly know how this works but
here to clear it up for us I guess is
our on-the-ground black lives matter
college correspondent Desmond black
Desmond tell us what's going on out
there make sense of it for us yes well
you have to understand that with this
given situation the ends justify the
means because it served to draw
awareness I don't to the discrepancy in
privilege in the systemic / discrepancy
okay between white and black students
and it started a dialogue - okay that's
what we always started a dialogue
Desmond like this last time when you
started a dialogue we saw what happened
these cities like like Baltimore
Ferguson the dialogue didn't work out so
well is this what you mean by starting a
dialogue but that's an essay though
that's that's an essay what could you
possibly be studying where this is
accepted as a legitimate essay Desmond
my major is humanities okay okay let's
see that seems to me like your problem
is what's your minor Desmond here I
don't certainly don't want to lump
everybody in because we've had black
guests on this show from the left and
right who are able to make sound
arguments and I don't think that you
represent I don't even think that you
represent all of black lives matter but
it seems that you personally Desmond are
a piece of a little bit maybe a piece of
sheet yeah okay no all right our black
lives matter correspondent you'll be
seeing a lot of him probably before we
get to I guess here's a topic I wanted
to get into
you guys are mutes today literally
you're sitting there with like zeros
giving the floor to our guests
what raised okay you had on the phone
before the hell completely alone I've
been talking a lot now it's like I feel
like Robin watching his parents die in
the trap he's out talking about a victim
and networking again Chris O'Donnell
Warner Brothers jokes so um here's
something I got an email from a college
student I've had this quite a quite a
bit messy you know when I'm on college
campus and our our professors always
talk about right-wing extremists they
always talk about how conservatives are
extreme and how you know that some of
them say they used to be conservative in
the right-wing left them particular in
the age of Trump right-wingers are
accused of being too extreme and they've
said can you help us
make the case that that's that's not
true I would actually argue the opposite
and I want to lay out the case for you
today that everything from moderate left
to the current Democratic Party the DNC
they actually have a corner exclusively
on the political extreme in the United
States as men right I don't I don't
think that the right wing is such a big
tent now I don't think it's capable of
being as extremists as the left
certainly can take maybe a 0.1 percent
in attribute it but I'm talking about as
an actual platform so what do you mean
okay let me lay out a case for you and
you can correct me if I'm wrong let's
take the big issues abortion that's an
issue at the right wing extremists by
the way right wing extremists we've
actually bombed abortion clinics when
they bring that out you could count on
both hands how many times that's
actually happened single digit numbers
okay but okay most conservatives are
pro-life we'll give you that we believe
life begins at conception but we're past
that now roe v-- wade was passed so
let's look to the super EXTREME example
of the supreme court well not nominee
anymore but justice or sick had you ever
met President Trump personally not until
my interview in that interview did he
ever ask you to overrule roe v wade no
senator what would he have done if he if
he had asked senator I would have walked
out the door he's about to bomb a clinic
here's the thing the middle fight from
the right is we just at this point we
don't want to pay for somebody else's
abortion and we want to herb them at
this butcher certainly the most horrific
of them let's contrast that with the
left's whose policy is taxpayer-funded
abortion on demand no questions asked
period their recent presidential
candidate and Hillary Hillary Clinton by
the way didn't specify Somali in the
first trimester a couple weeks she
believes that the unborn in the United
States basically up until the head
leaves the birth canal have no
constitutional rights period ask you
about some comments that she made over
the weekend on Meet the Press regarding
abortion you said quote the unborn
person doesn't have constitutional
rights so my question is at what point
does someone have constitutional rights
and are you saying that a child on its
due date just hours before delivery
still has no constitutional rights under
our law that is the case
an extremist because I think that that's
bone-chilling ly scary let's move on to
economics taxes okay we're the
extremists right this is what the media
says them right they're just they've
moved so far right
economically this wouldn't be a party
sounds like they're a chorus yeah let's
talk taxes okay on the right many of us
myself included want a flat tax some
people don't see that as extreme I
certainly don't you make a hundred
thousand dollars pay ten thousand make a
million or a hundred thousand dollars
that seems fair to me but let's take
that off the table okay let's take the
flat tax the income tax off the table
let's see if we can find a middle ground
on the right the extremists that we are
we have we see that we have a highest
corporate tax rate in the entire
industrialized world and we don't want
to lower it to the lowest rate we just
want to lower it to a rate that's
competitive with your oh so beloved
socialist European counterparts if you
were doing well but yeah just fantastic
yeah yeah things are golden it's it's
extreme to want to lower the highest
corporate tax rate to a middle level
more extreme than Bernie Sanders being
okay with a ninety percent income tax
radical socialist white the Eisenhower
was president I think the highest
marginal tax rate was something like
ninety it was 90 when you think about
ninety percent you don't think that's
obviously too high again no good solid
this is just a room full of extremists
who are being flagged on the terror
watch list we want you to keep more of
your money we're jerks I know they're
saying Bernie Sanders is extreme right
because he's never been mainstream okay
is it more extreme to want to lower the
corporate tax rate or allow people to
keep more of what they've earned than
Hillary Clinton wanting to raise the
estate tax the decks death tax to sixty
five percent which by the way is a tax
on tax it's more extreme to believe that
you should be able to keep more of what
you earn it's more extreme for people I
guess the extreme right wingers to
believe that we should be competitive
with the rest of the industrialized
world with our corporate tax rates than
it is to want to tax somebody more than
half on an already tax let's move on to
race relations
consider it as a racist right this is
the argument when it comes to race
re-adjust you're so out of touch you can
check your priveledge okay well let's
get into that on the right the extreme
view that we have is we want to do away
with affirmative action that's the most
extremist view we have that's what
though that's what the flag is for yep
we want to judge people based on the
content of the character as it were I
believe somebody uttered that too was
probably the member of the planned
fashion extreme probably white guy let's
let's take that and contrast that with
quotas segregated graduation and safe
spaces as you see in libraries and
Harvard after graduation now and even
the DNC going as far as supporting a
borderline terrorist group in black
lives matter so it's it's a it's not
extreme to support a group black lives
matter who have been the root cause of
many a cop car burning but it is extreme
for us to say hey maybe you shouldn't
support those people who are burning the
cop cars we want to open a dialogue well
do you want to open the car Raider it's
on fire climate change this is the one
where we're accused of being extreme all
the time again this is for kids who are
in college when they talk about
right-wing extremists let's let's check
all the boxes and you can send me your
tweets at s Crowder most of us on the
right I think most people in this room
accept the concept of climate change I
think most of us if you look at the
polls accept that humans might be a
contributing significant contributing
factor now we're called extremists or
science deniers simply if we don't
believe that it's an imminent
catastrophe that only the federal
government can fix the same people who
run your post office
we're extreme science and I you know
what climate change might be happening
humans might be contributing but I don't
think the EPA can fix it
well let's contrast that with the left
who they believe in carbon tax is
putting entire industries out of work
proposing the punishment of climate
sceptics as Bernie Sanders and
non-scientists guy in chief bill nye
then we can bring that don't we have his
quote from Bernie Sanders yeah yeah
along with supporting binding
resolutions including things like
population control taken from the
one-child policy of China it's extreme
for us is I don't think the federal
government can solve the problem of SUVs
and cow farts but it's
not extreme to be right in line with the
policy that led to babies being drowned
in Chinese bathtubs I just again I I
know I'm probably out of fish I don't
see the extremism of guns this is the
one of course work right gun-toting
rednecks clinging to your guns and
religion let's talk about this guns okay
you're an extremist if you believe that
the Second Amendment applies to all I
buy law-abiding citizens if you believe
that the Second Amendment is
self-explanatory it applies to all
law-abiding citizens the left considers
you an extremist let's contrast that
with the official dissenting views and
the landmark Heller vs. DC case where
liberals like justice Stevens argued
that actually private citizens have no
right to own a firearm whatsoever even
if the purposes are lawful oh good lord
it's extreme for us to say the Second
Amendment allows private citizens to
have firearms but it's not extreme for
Justice Stevens who have actually said
that there is no common law right to
self-defense it's extreme for me to want
to carry if I'm not a criminal we all
support background checks if you're a
felon if you're a violent criminal you
don't get a gun that's an extreme point
of view not to say you don't have the
right to protect your family this is
even getting the issue of the open
borders from the left the the idea that
no people are illegal which of course is
apparently far more moderate than the
extreme view of believing that people
should come here legally and respect the
process he's in place like my mother
who's a legal immigrant and pays taxes
the self-respecting American citizen
sucker the one that's most important to
me we talk this is the one that ever was
easy they talk about social justice
warriors but they don't really
understand the root cause but again it's
all it's all a part of the prism of
leftism
freedom of speech here's why you hate
fat land well blue haired feminists okay
why am I in extremists why is everyone
here considered an extremist to what is
required to be considered a free speech
extremists to the left okay it's simple
do you believe that the freedom of
speech is absolutely period is that do
you believe it nonviolent even offensive
offensive speech is absolute anyone in
this room and you leave that's protected
by the First Amendment
recordings of days left you're an
extremist fantastic yeah it's more
extreme to believe that freedom of
speech even offensive speech is absolute
then it is for 51 percent of current
Democrats to want to ban
speech and many of them you wanted to go
as far as simply banning any anti-muslim
bigotry speech Lord and here's the crazy
thing right I'm an extremist because
they lost second let's look let's ask
the questions who determines what hate
speech is exactly who decides what
extreme speech is detectable and here's
something but isn't it funny that were
deemed extremists by the people who
conveniently isn't it convenient for
them that the big government left that
those answers consistently and
exclusively lie with those in positions
of political power because they can't be
extremists only people like you and I
not possible maybe that's our the
official platform of the left all of
this leads to when we're talking about
free speech was as which I it's the
First Amendment how important is it
number one number one Ben Zakai News one
time what law do you think that or do
you believe that the Second Amendment is
important is your right like freedom of
speech or something because it's
literally right up there with the
freedom of speech you don't even have to
pounce if you're on an iPhone you have
to scrub one to stop they died like 20
years old back then we were right so
they have a new they're gonna prioritize
writing the most important ones first
cuz death could come at any moment
number one freedom speech right okay for
number two shoot that guy that said
something wrong number two black powder
and lead balls let me make sure this is
right for welcoming all the speech with
that if I get to nothing else if the
guys packing on the other side of you
probably control your map a little bit
yeah and this is what we're seeing as
extremists for believing this and maybe
this is why are all the things that
we've outlined are so considered extreme
this is why the official platform of the
left makes it incapable for their
members to answer very simple questions
on the first amendment let's see will
you tell us here today simply this is a
long lip I warn you but it's important
will never entertain or advance a
proposal that criminalizes speech
against any religion that seemed so much
better I would I want to as I said
before you referenced as context for
your question well there's no context no
questions asked just asking you you've
already let me ask a new question where
you tell us here today that this
administration's Department of Justice
will never entertain or advance a
proposal that criminalizes speech
against any religion
that seemed straightforward again that's
not a hard question well it's really not
bad no I'm pretty you don't need a
number-two pencil in a scantron of
justice will never entertain or advance
a proposal to criminalize speech against
any religion again sir if you Perez this
question will you tell us here today
that this administration's Department of
Justice will never entertain or advance
a proposal that criminalizes speech
against any religion again sir if
looking for a way to fit that clip in
for a long time so okay let me read it
for those who weren't clear on the
question let me crystallize it for you
for the left to believe that you are an
extremist all that is required is
someone like that to ask you the
question hold on a second do you promise
that you will not sign any bill or
support any bill that criminalizes any
speech of any kind if you were elected a
representative and you were able to
answer that question yes I promise I
will not ban speech of any kind you're
an extremist we'll be back with Alex
Epstein author of the moral case for
fossil fuels extremists
[Music]
let me tell you the truth about
YouTube's guidelines than the words of
YouTube's own owners at Google content
that is not advertised Saturday and the
[ __ ] YouTube friendly includes but is
not limited to sexually suggestive
content violence harassment proposed to
the troubles and finally controversial
subjects including subjects related to
or political conflicts natural disasters
and tragedies even of graphic images of
YouTube's and upper left root social
justice world's who have captured down
with these myths
non-sensory
start by joining $4.99 annually
continued content and the story with you
three step forward those who will guard
where the box lab army will be raised
the powerful will be ripped from their
gelatin safe spaces and cast out into
the ground through speech scale that
videos will continue to be uploaded at
monetization through sponsorships we
better join channel will survive and
they want deserve true freedom of speech
yes we are doing so it's membership the
YouTube channel will be allowed to
survive
[Music]
[Music]
all right another pogo bump that's the
first time for people who are hearing it
over to you Tuesday's glad to have our
next guest on so he was actually here's
the truth we were going to have him
booked a while back and then something
happened it we we are horrible people
and we bumped him and then we just
didn't get back in touch until Patrick
Moore in his interview that's right in
front of a memory trigger we said well
you know on Alex Epstein actually who
wrote the moral case for fossil fuels
was supposed to have a debate regarding
climate change regarding fossil fuels
and the person backed out so now I've
kind of ruined it but I've ruined the
crescendo but Aladin author of the moral
case for fossil fuels thanks for being
here brother hey good to be here
so what was that Patrick Moore was
telling us about you had a debate
scheduled and then the guy just didn't
show up fill us in there yes I've done a
lot of debates over the years and 2011 I
challenged Greenpeace to debate and we
actually found someone to debate me but
over the years and particularly since
the book the moral case for fossil fuels
came out which is pretty effective I
would say arrogantly it's been really
hard to find people and we managed to
find this guy Terry tamanna who runs the
Leonardo DiCaprio Foundation and a big
event offered me the opportunity to
debate him and the sole reason I did it
is because of the prominence of Leonardo
DiCaprio yeah and then I prepare for and
then a week in advance I hear that with
no explanation this guy pulls out he
cited quote urgent business
unquote maybe had to go to the bathroom
did they give you anything else after
that no and he didn't even it wasn't
even man enough to come to me himself
which I would obviously do if you know
I'm the only reason I would pull out
would be you know the plague or you know
new case of polio or something like that
so right they I got a replacement who
was the former governor of Colorado bill
Ritter but it just wasn't the same thing
and on top of that the moderator
completely broke the rules to give the
other guy way more time to talk and it
was 24 minutes so this is pretty much a
fiasco but you know really so we go from
arrogant to very humble we appreciate it
well I'm not saying I'm the sole cause
you know if you want to search aleksef
son debate on youtube you can see some
of these debates and you can maybe see
why these guys don't want it to be well
sure let me ask you so what kind of
things do you debate obvious
it's somewhat self-explanatory in your
book title the moral case for fossil
fuels but lay that out for people
watching who maybe don't know we've
talked about that in the show quite a
bit having been to the climate summits
myself and and actually gone out of the
nice resorts where they spend time but
but you're the expert Alex yeah I think
it is really important to decide what
topic to debate because I think even in
the lead-up you mentioned something
about climate change and I think climate
change is very vague term first of all
yeah but it's the wrong thing to debate
because climate change the the actual
issue there is co2 emissions does
increasing co2 levels cause some serious
problem that offsets the benefits of
fossil fuels so you're dealing with a
situation where you have fossil fuels
and you have benefits and you have
concerns and whenever you have such a
situation the real issue is overall is
this a good thing or not it'll be just
like vaccines you look at the benefits
and you look at the concerns and you try
to do so objectively yeah so that you
can advance human flourishing as much as
possible really nice to have you there
that's so it's a sliding scale but
essentially that you say that because
you know we did go from global warming
to climate change anytime there is a
change it is important to note on the
timeline it becomes more generalized as
you've said which makes it less and less
possible to debate so I just think
people should should note that and be
aware of the next iteration of it but
continue and and in general just notice
when things are precisely defined or or
not and and also whether people are
careful about the magnitude whether they
differentiate between mild and
catastrophic so the analogy I like to
use is vaccines imagine somebody says to
you well Stephen you're in favor of
vaccines let's say you are you must be a
vaccine side effect denier right because
vaccines have side effects you know so
how could you be in favor of them and
you might say well I think they have
these unique benefits that you can't get
from anything else and I think those
outweigh the side effects exactly the
same with fossil fuels right i assess
that the benefits far far outweigh the
side effects and i precisely look at
both where as the opposition they only
look at the negatives and they
dramatically exaggerate them so they
have this narrative of oh if fossil
fuels impact climate at all that must be
a catastrophe and there's no benefit to
offset it so it's just garbage thinking
well you also
both the positives and negatives and
then on the positive sides from what
I've read you assess not only the the
moral sort of quandary that they try to
present but also the economic you know
sort of that the technological
development and there are a lot of lay
there are a lot of things to unpack
there where it's not just hey this is
good or bad for the environment like you
said do we know definitively how good or
how bad what the ramifications are and
how does that sort of coincide with what
people in third-world countries need to
advance to be able to live to feed
themselves and again but this this just
comes from someone who's a generalized
climate denier and by that I mean I
don't think the FT I don't think the EPA
can fix manmade climate change if you
know Florida won't be around in two
years that's really all I think it's
interesting when we talk about this
issue of the moral case why use that
term and the reason I'm using moral is
because it's the overarching concept
that includes things like economic and
environment and the key for me is how I
define moral versus how my opponents
define moral because my standard of
morality is what advances human
flourishing and their standard of
morality is what minimizes human impact
and if you really want to minimize human
impact we shouldn't have cities we
shouldn't have kids and we should praise
North Korea as a better country than
South Korea yes we should just have no
humans I was up the Cancun climate
summit when I remember Ted Turner got up
and proposed effectively China's
one-child policy we just talked about
that and no one around to the climate
some was like oh my god this is horrible
he's talking about the policy that let
the girls being drown in bathtubs
everyone just said yeah one-child that's
occurred the overpopulation
I mean talk about immoral I feel like
I'm in Blade Runner
that's hilarious to me only because when
I was a freshman at Duke University I
almost got kicked out of the school
because a lecturer came in and started
talking about the virtue of China's
policies in dehumanizing the planet and
everyone else was nodding and I somehow
ended up giving a speech of my own and
the guy left the room and I was told
that that I shouldn't go to Duke any
more if I was going to do this yes
exactly don't you go to Duke Oh we'll
make up a fake rape story out of you
young apps teen yeah it's it was
remarkable that can cause climate summit
just everything the whole message was
it's not that I it's not that any of us
don't care about the environment you
know we want to pick stuff up I hate it
when i see people littering it
that we want to see people live you know
I would kill a thousand monkeys if it
meant saving one human I know it sounds
terrible it doesn't sound nice but um
does this is essentially the equation
with your sort of your opposition order
they just say well listen Alex do you
also have a moral obligation to if this
does impact the environment to try and
bring us to alternative sources of
energy and I know I've heard that
argument from them what do you say to
them and is there some truth there well
the first question you raised it has to
do with what's the relationship between
environment and human wellbeing and for
me it's a subordinate relationship which
means I want a good environment to
advance human flourishing so I judge
environmental impacts as positive or
negative based on their impact on humans
so I generally want to minimize
pollution but I'm very Pro development
versus the other side what they want to
do is just minimize human impact and by
they I mean really anyone who holds this
idea in any form of minimising human
impact and if you're optimizing for
minimizing human impact you are going to
dehumanize the planet you're gonna take
away resources people need to live
you're gonna take away their power
you're going to take away their freedom
and that's the direction that we're
going so if we have a pro human goal
then we will care about our environment
if we have an anti impact goal then
we'll sacrifice humans to the
environment it's a very good point you
know it almost becomes just a
reiteration of Gaia you know it's
basically mother earth worship at this
boy yeah when I say Gaia people say you
mean like that message abort it used to
have all the anime porn I'm like no the
Internet ruins everything
but let's how do you balance this so it
kind of for people who are listening
right now who were raised in the
generation will climate change global
warming slash climate change exists it's
man-made it's catastrophic we need to
fix this
what is the moral case moving forward
what's the balancing act there I know
right now we're dependent on fossil
fuels if Alex Epstein could get the
world to listen to them right now what
do we do I'd say two things one is
carefully measure positives and
negatives and two is freedom so
carefully measure positives and
negatives means if you're talking about
the climate impact of co2 emissions you
want to assess what if anything to those
see
to emissions due to the livability of
the climate that's the key idea if you
care about humans it's about the
livability it's not about change
it's not about warming those are
derivative ideas the key is livability
and if you measure this the livability
of the climate since major fossil fuels
began 80 years ago around the world has
increased by a factor of 50 so you are
150th as likely to die from extreme heat
extreme cold flood drought as you were
80 years ago now how can this be
possible it's because there is no Gaea
nature doesn't give us a safe climate
that we make dangerous gives us a really
dangerous climate that we need to make
safe and technology industry all powered
by fossil fuels that's made us almost
climate proof and so the real solution
to quote-unquote climate danger change
which be climate danger is technology
and guess what climate is a problem
we've mostly saw today ten to thirty
thousand people a year die globally from
climate danger it used to be three
million to ten million in a year how do
you measure that it's pretty
straightforward you just aggregate you
take a bunch of categories so you take
heat related deaths you know from
extreme heat cold it's much easier to do
now than it was in the past so in the
past they tend to underreport it but
even then you have years in the 30s
where adjusted for population there were
10 million climate related deaths a year
globally by today's population today
again 10 to 30,000 climate is a
naturally caused problem that requires
human technology as a solution the
people who are afraid of climate are
either disingenuous or they have a
primitive pre technology mindset that
tells us that we need to repent for our
climate sins
instead of conquering nature with
technology so once again in that
confessional booth it's just al gore
hair plot look through the slot said so
think about the the the Blues er you
talk about in Montreal think about how
many people probably back then if they
had generators but the homes that keep
the EPA keep their breathing machine
people died during the API you think
about all the situations for technology
and basic elevation is we have to get
going but it's funny that you bring that
up because first off he's he's a Jeff
Goldblum way
life finds away I think he's right but
you know as simple as when I was a kid
we had them come in with their Sesame
Street classes and never let the water
run because we're losing fresh water and
this was me as a child now I'm not
saying that everything I asked was
correct but looking back it's the
mindset that you're pretty much
expressing I remember saying well hon a
second didn't we just learned that the
earth is 70% water they said yes but
that's not all fresh water okay so it's
not they said yeah we're losing fresh
water that's it okay but is there do we
have some way to like be salt the ocean
as well yeah desalinization we do but
it's very expensive and it's very
difficult to do that's okay but won't
that just get better and cheaper this is
me at seven and you know well uh never
let the water on they flipped a switch
and never let the water run run with the
mascots now is you're supposed to stop
asking questions and it comes down to
technology as a kid I thought well it's
gonna get better
it told me to shut up so yeah let me
look at how good that philosophy is and
how how rare it is to just have a pro
human Pro technology philosophy the so
called pro technology environmentalists
their core solution is to withdraw
technology to withdraw consumption to
withdraw prosperity versus the mentality
of hey let's use a new technology to
make things better all the time so as
Joe Rogan put it you know we don't have
a water problem we have a salt problem
and we need a technological solution
yeah anti anti technology or they are
Pro spending technology spending
resources in ways that are that like
Germany would spend computer one of our
interns in Germany right you know that
obviously they had to sell some of their
energy at a negative rate when they
deserve plus it so and and then they
those aren't real tech so a technology
that's subsidized for ideological
reasons is an insult to technology
technology as that which consumers will
buy because it's more advanced yeah when
they're on the free market that's a good
point otherwise if the government were
subsidizing phones this would be my
iPhone hello can you hear me now I don't
know I switch to sprint the guy's gonna
marry a dude did you know he's gay the
Verizon guys he does talks about a
brilliant ad campaign okay Alex Epstein
the off the the author of the book the
moral case for fossil fuels people can
buy that on Amazon right
yeah and to get everything just go to
industrial progress comm industrial
progress comm the moral case for fossil
fuels it's very compelling Alex brother
we'll have to have you back but I think
we have Ben Shapiro coming up bench pure
commitment zero coming up we gotta go we
gotta go
we'll have you back alright I guess
[Music]
you heard [ __ ] Bane it's an uprising
with hashtag mug club listen thank you
so much for people who've join us a lot
with better calm slash mug let people
who have not yet done it a lot of you I
know I can see some tweets why aren't
you talking more about Comey or why are
you discussing X topic more unlike
before where was a once a week show we
do a once a day show now Monday through
Thursday Minh jared has his show on
Friday again for mug Club members so we
cover the news it comes in every day so
if you want to see all of it and that
you can afford the 585 a month if you're
a student join a lot of credit calm /mo
Club its ironically what allows us to
keep free content occurring here on
YouTube and we're going to do a 7-day
free trial right now you can always do
that see our TV you can try it's free
for seven days we're going to actually
do it on YouTube here in the next couple
weeks so stay tuned for when that occurs
we'll be putting up every single show
for 7 days so you can see you're missing
out on and if you don't want to join you
don't have to but if you see the lights
go out sometime well I like what
happened I like that show you couldn't
afford the 585 a month also like 10
people are dependent on it do you want
the [ __ ] you want them to make some bread
you just have to find that it's 2 cups
of coffee or supporting a child in a
third world country but little coffees
what's important to you you can forego 2
cups of coffee get a curate you can't do
a cure egg lot of credit calm / mug Club
[Music]
I wish I could I wish I could go back
and forth there was a villain in
Marvel's called mojo who just move like
this imagine what you could you could
cut off the boxing ring that my hood I
don't know
speaking of intellectual boxing capacity
I don't know I'm trying to think of a
transition I'm not all the time and you
know I'm daily wire obviously as as much
as they're wildly popular but self
titled the ben shapiro show at ben
shapiro thank you for being with us sir
absolutely how are you doing Stephen
yella Crowder
it wears el Crowder from oh I see cuz
louder was Crowder no no no you got it
wrong it's remains a mystery my middle
name don't spill the beans not Kay
Jerrod
stop it it gives us a guy who didn't
know Johnny Mathis was we're just Thomas
Jarrett during the break how do you not
know who Johnny Mathis is ok bet it's
been a long week I'm not gonna lie I'm
getting like tinnitus and vertigo so our
opinion on Comey
yesterday and we're like we know this
isn't going to get it a ton of clicks
was just I think everybody is an
insufferable [ __ ] ha ha that's all I
just like I mean as you know that is my
general take on the universe yeah will
not argue with single word of that I
think that that is basically correct I
feel like I have aged 73 years in the
three and a half months since Trump took
the presidency so I am now 1,000 years
old because Obama also aged me
dramatically so yeah I'm like one of
those before after pictures that you
know they always show the president
before and after his presidency yeah but
that's me just covering these people so
yeah it's like the Dark Crystal after
the force takes out their life yeah and
it's just it's it's become that now and
and so it's only been it hasn't been 48
hours since he fired coaming you
understand that
I mean like what barely how is that
possible time is not a time is moving
backwards now we're now living in the
alternative timeline where Biff Eric
actually married Marty's mother excited
something happened here we hit 88 miles
per hour and and time has ceased to
exist it's it's it's all it's all over
okay so who do you want to which which
which a hold you want to talk about here
basically you're right everyone's an
a-hole so do we talk about call me being
an a-hole or trumping an a-hole or Sarah
Huckabee Sanders began a hole or Chuck
Schumer being an a-hole be a hole and
then we decide which one of them to
discuss also heard very commonly a truck
stops across the country so here is
something that I feel with with visa I
just the internet exists and we can see
that no one has been consistent my might
my odd sort of confliction with Comey is
I've always kind of felt bad for him in
the sense that he can't please everyone
but at the same like I feel I feel
empathy but at the same time I kind of
hate him I don't know how I've never
felt that way about anyone before okay
so we'll start with James a comb mediate
so Comey I said unless July that he
should be fired because that ridiculous
press conference over Hillary Clinton he
rewrote the law it was clearly be asked
he should have been fired then if Obama
had fired him it would've been for
different reasons then I would want to
fire him and this is where I have a
little bit of sympathy for the Democrats
because Comey is terrible at his job and
the Democrats are recognizing that he's
terrible at his job and he's terrible at
his job for different reason than Trump
thinks he's terrible at his job so in
such a his you can't say that somebody
should be fired and then be and then
also say well that's really weird the
reason why you just fired that we know
lots of people in our industry who we
think should be fired but if they got
fired for something that was totally
irrelevant or weird we'd be like that's
weird like why would you fire them for
that reason so I you know I don't mean
to let Democrats off the hook for their
hypocrisy here you know a lot of them
said he should've been fired back in
November after the October 28th letter I
said last week you should be fired I
said six days eight days ago now that he
should been fired at Silver Lake and he
listens to vinyl now he's everyone else
did exactly no I was at listen I was I
was doing this before was cool so I
thought I thought he should have been
fired a while ago but I also think there
are legitimate questions to be asked
like why did the firing happen now and
so basically there are three theories as
to why the firing happened now so that
with you mind because you're smarter
than me so let me put up with you mind
this is why I you know what I think very
well may be possible that Donald Trump
just doesn't have the self-awareness he
probably wanted a fire call me anyway
doesn't like him but he doesn't realize
that this is horrible timing there's no
evidence of the Russia thing I don't
miss this is yes exact no this is
exactly right so this is my theory
number three you and I agree on this I
think that you look at the personality
of Trump this wasn't like a well planned
out coup we're gonna nail this guy
because he's so close to the treasure
now we got to stop him Legos for for
Minecraft theory right
lay low for four months that just blow
everything up yeah I don't think so
be back soon waters like yeah yeah I
mean so so there's basically the
Democrat theory was that Trump fired
call me because he's trying to obstruct
the investigation but there's no
evidence that he's actually trying to
obstruct the investigation since it's
going on apparently normally so that one
just doesn't really hold a lot of water
by the same token the original excuse
that the administration gave was
obviously complete [ __ ] right I mean
when they were saying that we were
firing him because what he did back in
July and back in October like Trump was
sure and Comey back in October and then
he reappointed him to the FBI
directorship so clearly that was
nonsense
so he had two theories one from Trump
that was both fit and one from the
Democrats that was booked and then
there's the third theory which is that
Trump is just being stupid which is I
think fits the evidence pretty well
thank you probably what happened here is
that Donald Trump was pissed with Comey
because Comey keeps going on Capitol
Hill and refusing to say what Trump
knows is true which is that Trump is not
directly involved in any collusion with
Russia yeah it probably pisses Trump off
to no end
that people think that he's involved in
this collusion when he knows he's not
involved in the collusion yeah now one
thing that we understand about Trump is
that Trump also doesn't identify with
his aides
so if there is any evidence of collusion
it's not gonna be found about Trump
directly it's gonna be found about Paul
Manafort who legitimately was in the pay
of the Russians it's gonna be found
about Mike Flynn who legitimately was in
the pay of the Russians under you know
under some auspices or others and and so
Trump says well but those guys aren't me
so why are you bothering me about this
but I think in the political world goes
well wait a second if those guys were
actually doing that we don't have open
Internet yeah but if it turns out that
that's what was happening then we're
gonna get a year of what did Trump know
and when did he know it but Trump
doesn't see that Trump just says okay
well those guys are me so why is call me
keep bugging me like let me just say to
me we'll see how publicly he says to me
I have it's the proof for that guy get
rid of him yeah come in and then all the
people around him are sick defense and
morons and today I'll go let's do it
like what's the problem I mean well it's
it's fine cool let's do it and let's
give no explanation to our
communications people and probably
someone like Reince Priebus who has like
some semblance of a brain when it comes
to policy politics says you know what
why don't we try to get together like a
fig leaf let's get rod Rosenstein in
here to write some [ __ ] letter about
why we're doing this then we'll pretend
that it was the rod
in letter that really drove it and then
Trump goes on national television and
says oh yeah by the way that letter was
complete bull show we didn't need that
letter I was gonna fire him anyway
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is on national
team the letter by Penn she's on
national TV blaming the letter and again
and spikes are just on the corner
yelling nothing this is this is
basically a tire fire on top of a
dumpster fire on top of a ship fire and
all of it is just one conflagration of
joy with Trump supporters sitting in one
corner calling 80 underwater chess
magamaev Agra and Democrats on the other
side going clearly clearly the Russians
are coming and it's just it's all
nonsense it's all nonsense it's Trump
being stupid his people being stupid his
people being uninformed and him getting
mad at them because they're uninformed
and saying stupid things so Sarah
Huckabee Sanders ends up you know
looking terrible because she's out there
basically lying to people about why this
firing happened now do you think she was
lying I think she will quit legit to
fire call me that's the thing that's
amazing he turned something that could
have been totally fine and innocent into
something that is complete dumpster fire
because he lives in a world where the
things he does have no consequences
because when you're seven years old and
you've done nothing your entire life but
being told yes then at some point you're
gonna make a boo-boo and someone's gonna
tell you no and you're just not going to
pay any attention do it again recall
something I mean there a couple things
here that totally drive me up a wall
you've gone through like 25 things that
drive you it is important to note Donald
Trump is not under investigation
directly and I will say no I think
that's totally legitimate I actually
think if there are other people who have
colluded with Russia okay if that's
proven I honestly think if that were the
case they would have deliberately kept
Donald in the dark more cuz he can't
keep a secret I think they're like oh
yes mr. Putin hold on Donald I mean
Michelle yeah I'll call you back later
that's totally true and I think that I
think that Trump didn't even know who
mana fort was when he hired him yeah I
think that he didn't care what Flynn was
doing on his off time Trump only thinks
about Trump so why would anybody around
him tell him what was going on with any
other stuff
Trump was probably very innocently going
out to these rallies ensuring for
WikiLeaks even if manifold was in the
back room actually like making out with
Julian Assange like we have no idea what
was going on there but here so here are
the two things that are driving me up a
wall for the next thirty seconds then
we'll get to the other 100 things that
drive me up a wall okay okay one is
I'm old enough to remember when during
the election cycle it was just the worst
thing in the world that Loretta Lynch
got on a plane with Bill Clinton well
Loretta Lynch was presumably
investigating Hillary you remember this
this is a bad thing I remember it being
really terrible in fact it was such a
bad thing that Comey felt the need to do
the October 28th letter because he felt
that Loretta Lynch had blown her
credibility yeah Donald Trump went on
national television with Lester Holt and
said after his election he had James
Comey for dinner Comey requested the
dinner and at the dinner Comey wanted to
hit him up so that he could remain FBI
director and they had a full
conversation about whether Trump was
under investigation no you're not
supposed to do that no but now what race
is Lester Holt anyway because we have a
betting pool we can not figure it out
see this is something I'm not gonna do
I'm not gonna play that's because you
can't guess it is a guessing game it's a
roll of the dice and you know that
there's a 50/50 chance you're right or
wrong I think that was the one thing
that pissed me off again the second
thing is that Mike Pence was in the dark
right he looks really crappy because
he's on TV for a day saying that this is
because Rod Rosenstein wrote this letter
and Rod Rosenstein we know is above
reproach and that's why Trump did this
is because of Rod Rosenstein this and
Rod Rosen see and then it turns out of
course that that's nonsense and Trump
just did it anyway it was an excuse okay
I remember when Mike Flynn was fired
supposedly because he lied to Mike Pence
remember yeah maybe that was the excuse
right he was fired because he lied to my
Pence and make my pence look bad let's
see who in the past 72 hours in may Mike
Pence look like a stupid ass hmm you get
the sense and no one knows what they're
doing it's because no one knows what
they're doing by your emergency food
yes exactly by your hybrid seeds let me
ask you this honestly like you talked
about Sarah Huckabee Sanders and Mike
Flynn do you think like she's I love the
Tara Huckabee Sanders is the better
version of Sean Spicer I mean the
something like she's the Lou Gehrig who
just Wally PIPP Sean Spicer I mean like
what yeah what's that what's the bad
Bert what yeah I know what I know and
and Sean Spicer is not the Luger he's
just the Greg Louganis who hit his head
in the back of the diving board and
spread hae-jin to the pool at the
Olympics didn't tell them was happening
let me ask you this do you think that
someone like Sarah Huckabee Sanders or
Sean Spicer or Mike Flynn vice president
Mike Flynn do you think they're out
there and they're kind of fibbing what I
say Mike Pence either
gosh I'm getting mixed up here do you
think they're out there fibbing or do
you just think that they are so
ill-equipped being sent out there and
not given information that it's
impossible to do their ladder ladder I
think that I think that Trump does stuff
and then he's like react go yeah you
know he's basically the Joker and that
sentry breaks a pool cue and to and it
says okay there's only one slot open and
that's what he's like with his
communications team and so we're having
tryouts and so who can kiss my ass the
most brazenly the national TV and make
me feel good about myself cuz I'm
watching the briefing
oh good here's the thing about all of
this I'm getting bashed on Twitter
because I'm being too critical of Trump
if you're smart you want Trump to have a
successful presidency folks or the mayor
crowd okay if you weren't from to have a
successful presidency it would help if
you would stop doing this and pull his
head directly out of his colon okay
enough you guys here's the thing this
should have been a good week for Trump
right remember last week yet his
triumphal meeting at the White House
with all the House Republicans after
passing Trump care a bill I didn't like
but it was a political victory for him
sure and now we should have spent this
entire week etna just pulled out of
obamacare like the entire company pulled
out of obama i know he's such a great
that'd be the number one store in
America and he'd be saying to the Senate
look Obama care is collapsing do
something about it he'd be on the move
we'd be talking about tax reform instead
what are we talking about we're talking
about how loud he how horribly
he blew this particular the Comey firing
how he sat on the giantest whoopee
cushion in the room how he set himself a
landmine and jumped on it with both feet
we're talking about that and by the way
the time the time is running on
Obamacare repeal I or were it's not
really Obamacare people is running on
Trump care by the by the middle of June
this thing's over right reconciliation
dies until the fall if they don't do
this now and he just lost another week
doing the stupidity he's gonna lose
another couple of weeks because of this
and his approval ratings are in the
toilet the congressional approval
ratings are in the toilet like was a job
he needs to do a good job and that
doesn't excuse Democrats for being who
they are right now hypocrites they are
terrible they are taking advantage of a
bad situation but you know they're gonna
maybe he's the one who reads the poem
the snake at his at his rallies doesn't
he know the Democrats in the media are
gonna be the snake anyway yeah why would
you possibly give them the material oh I
do think I do think there's the other
side of the coin I was watching CNN
today and Wolf Blitzer and they didn't
have a single person on the panel who
would correct anything and they're
saying Donald Trump directly under
investigation for an obscenity like this
is
CNN it's Wolf's lowest score ever on
celebrity jeopardy Blitzer so you know I
hate that guy I know you can say he
would seem so benign but like my regime
and it's just these horrible thoughts
and feelings just bubble up in a few
mediocre yeah it is you know I will say
this because I I was never on the never
Trump bandwagon wasn't a huge fan
obviously I wouldn't say as gung-ho as
you but I want to see him do well and it
has been as someone who works in news so
hard to follow this week because someone
will be trotted out they'll say
something and then two hours later it's
completely contradicted by somebody else
in this administration
I don't know how Americans any American
right now thinks that they have a shot
because it is difficult for
professionals to make sense of this and
maybe even after the time of this
episode when someone's watching this
tomorrow what we're saying right now
will make no sense I totally agree with
this and I think that this is why the
media bias really does come into play in
a major way I mean I was watching CNN
yesterday for some god-awful reason and
you're exactly right every person they
were caught was like here is here's
Bernie Sanders talking about why Trump
should be prosecuted and now that'll be
followed by you know this other house
from the house Democrat who says that he
should be prosecuted followed by here's
David Axelrod comments on why should
prosecuted it's just a just a lineup of
people who hate Trump but the problem is
that's why you have to have an
administration that presents a clear and
concise position which by the way was
something Trump was actually quite good
at during the campaign yeah in certain
areas of his campaign he would say in
one sentence what's your ISIS policy
well bomb the [ __ ] out of them right and
then every big o make sense to me okay
doesn't make no sense I'm not exactly
that's right it makes a certain type of
sense but this does what he's doing now
there's not even a counter-attack
because the Democrats say here's a very
clear narrative okay there we have the
router and under investigation by the
Russians Trump fires the guy who's in
charge of the investigation right that's
the entire narrative right in one
sentence and the with the semicolon and
the and the Republicans have no reply to
that because Trump hasn't even given
them one they're just spinning around
wildly like tops and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is getting dizzy and falling off
the podium you just don't know how are
we even supposed to set our defensive
battle lines to defend this when he
doesn't know where the defensive battle
lines are he drives he's gonna do stuff
and panicle and see what we do up there
here's how he can finish this I mean
honestly he could fix it
in here we have to give you okay we have
to then we have to wrap you and give you
the give you the mop the hook so I
apologize but wrap it up no worries okay
so the final look if he wants to solve
this if he wants to solve this all he
has to do is appoint somebody who's well
respected on both sides of the aisle to
the head of the FBI that's all it does
that this whole thing guys immediately
but you know this is this is a cloud
that he just won't let die and he won't
let it die because Trump is Trump and it
comes with a good and it comes with the
bad well I think most important here is
you know for a long time people were
mocking anyone who was saying listen I
for example me I wasn't never Trump I'm
going but we've got to keep him
accountable remember people would have
the memes port no principles oh what are
your principles matter if you never win
well guess what you can't only focus in
the short-term battles and lose the war
and you can only have a few more weeks
like this until you start losing the war
it's a real problem and I think of
anything the Mogga people the super
hardcore Trump fans should want to keep
him accountable more than anyone because
right now they're being embarrassed
because of him ben shapiro at the Daily
wire the ben shapiro show the guy can
talk a mile a minute for I don't know
hours that's what he does every day
thank you so much brother we'll have to
have you back tension bed go dick is
there next we will be back after this
wrapping this up
[Music]
many of you are still unaware of the
items available at louder with Crowder
shop calm not only do they make you look
and feel better but they serve a
multitude of purposes like our socialism
is for [ __ ] shirts assisting in
identifying potential allies I think
it's pretty funny or our bad hombres
firearm t-shirt helping you know who to
avoid I'm gonna take that shirt to mean
you support some kind of firearm
registry or this one hey look it's my
face I hate it though louder with
Crowder shop calm isn't for everyone but
can i buy the mug from the shop without
joining the mug Club no the rest of you
check out the merchandise at Lauder with
Crowder shop calm today
[Music]
that was for the fan who loves the the
bumbles face you know what good it's a
good face such a good face thank you a
good bench bureau always fun had to cut
him off because the guy goes over time
he were at the Oscars you would just
hear the theme song for half of his
speech wouldn't hear half the second
half of his speech just play it well now
find hot just Hans Zimmer anything
playing this guy just won't shut up
a smart guy I will say that Spencer of
yours I don't every with him on
everything but when we're tracking this
yeah III think I feel I agree with you I
feel that exactly I go okay now I don't
feel so bad
sure sure n you understand why let this
datum yeah I can't be the owners
exasperated with this week I just wanted
it to end I'm like I just I don't want
to have to talk about call me one more
time or hear one more screw up I'm done
with it I'm over it and if in fact as
far as you know we often wrap this up I
feel like I covered most of it earlier
with the extremest segment but for those
asking about it yeah it'll probably be
cut on its own segment for YouTube as a
reference and we'll have the sources
available it's one of those deals the
whole idea of extremism that just your
right-wing extremists that we've talked
about this before
it's just repeated enough where a lot of
people believe it well I'm concerned but
I'm not one of those right-wing
extremists
well I'm conservative but I'm a
compassionate conservative sort of I'm
I'm reasonable yeah I'm concerned about
unreasonable and we've been allowed to
sit by the way we will host anybody on
here for discussion for a civil
discussion but I don't think it's reaiiy
don't think 90% of the policies proposed
by today's regressive left are
reasonable and only a 65 percent death
tax is reasonable I don't think
taxpayer-funded abortion on demand up
until the head pokes out is reasonable I
don't and I'll argue those ideas because
I think they're so unreasonable I can
argue those ideas in a civil way that's
what's that's what's funny when you have
the confidence in the logic of the basis
of your ideas you can you can argue with
someone who you think their ideas are so
absurd and you can be civil because
you're not you're not insecure it's like
a woman one mate when they get into a
fight with a guy they just go full-bore
you ever have that will you sister yeah
they don't control themselves guys are
able to because they they're confident
in their strength
you know we rip each other and the women
just like they grab your hair and they
gawd your eyes said rubbing your
forehead with a cheese grater like a
backyard wrestling they take it too far
because they're not confident in their
physical abilities and they shouldn't be
women are weak so it is one of those
just repeated enough and you know what
they just well so you think of flat tax
that's extreme why when someone just
acts is that they try and throw away
your idea why is that extreme well what
we just we think that America it's this
like Michael more recently in Bernie
Sanders echoed it we like to think of us
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
Society that's what these right-wing
it's you well why why is that absurd why
is it absurd to think that most
grown-ass men can pull their self
themselves up by their bootstraps kind
of like Ben Carson when he said about
public housing he said well you know I
think we should help those the weakest
among us are disabled but I don't think
that we should make people super
comfortable who are able-bodied and
capable of finding work can you believe
ben Carson said it yeah but usually if
someone is just trying to poo pood
should try and dismiss an idea or can
you believe that just think about it for
a second and usually you work through
the process go oh this person is trying
to pull one over on me yeah I can
believe it the thing the idea is now
that we believe to be extreme the Second
Amendment that you can own and produce
and protect yourself the idea that you
should be an autonomous human being
capable of providing for your own family
and not suckling at the taxpayer teat
the idea of rugged independence of
freedom of speech of the idea that you
can pull yourself up by your bootstraps
these ideas now that we try and paint or
the left tries to paint as extremism
they used to be truths held to be
self-evident you could not go but you
could not go back even you know what
I'll I'll be I'll be liberal with this
you couldn't even go back to JFK's era
in short of the actual communists who
now hijacked the wing of the Democratic
Party find mainstream Democrats when JFK
was president who would think that any
of these ideas were extremists so you
know what it's not that bad sometimes if
someone just says it's being an
extremist is not a bad thing if that's
what it boils down to I get an email a
little time like you know I have to
Fraser you didn't directly in the
entertainment history you're in college
and I just don't want them to think I'm
an extremist what's so bad what people
are going to say you're
extremists they think you're a terrorist
because you believe in a flat tax and an
eight month old baby has the right to
live I'm okay being an extremist
I don't we should get a hashtag going
extremists I think ever in this room's
an extremist and I'm cool with it I'm
Thai I'm no longer going to try and act
as though I'm not because all of these
ideas are extreme to the left okay let's
go ahead together this next week and be
extremists just be extreme and be open
about your extremism and see how people
react maybe you'll change a mind or two
if not they'll probably hate you anyway
you know why because they're the real
extremists also they suck their asses
they are jackasses see you next week
monday from Oakland members
[Music]